Hello world,
it's Saroj and I've now selected over
800 school of AI deans across 400 cities
globally.
In the past week.
These deans have been hard at work
building infrastructure to welcome wizards
from their respective communities
to learn more about AI technology.
They've been creating Facebook groups,
meetup groups, Twitter accounts.
It has been so incredible to see.
School of AI chapters are safe
spaces for wizards everywhere.
They're a place to meet likeminded people,
learn,
get inspired and educate others.
The deans are guardians of our core
values and mission and will help guide you
on your Ai Journey.
Some deans have even held their
first local class already,
which makes me very happy to see.
I've attached a link to a listing
of all school of AI chapters.
It's in the video description.
Find Your City,
join your local group and
attend the first class.
Make sure to offer to help your
local dean in any way you can.
Some are still looking for suitable
venues and or local sponsorships.
It is truly an amazing time to be
alive and let's spread this AI power.